what you are gonna see behind me is the
gauntlet of superstitions it doesn't
really matter how superstitious I am
because this is all gonna be enough to
ruin my life the mirror is the one that
I'm like oh I know what this is about
this means I'm not gonna get married
there will never be a ring on this
finger this is so stupid my cat's
probably gonna be dead when I come home
my girlfriend's gonna break up with me
I'm gonna lose my job what else could
happen it's a very common condiment in
the household and I'm just gonna pour
one out for my homies you know why this
is probably bad luck because it's
wasteful that's why you salt there it is
I'm not gonna throw it over my shoulder
because that would be the common sense
thing to do I don't care you're not the
one's gonna die lose their hair all
right so we've got an umbrella umbrella
is the one that I think I'm least afraid
of because I don't believe in umbrellas
I believe in Jesus
this one is messing you up too bad I'm
feeling good about this the salt thing
I'm not feeling awesome about though I
really want to toss that okay I have
avoided walking under ladders all my
life and there's like a million of them
no I don't want to do this all right
we're just gonna calmly stroll through
the ladders by future nice knowing you
well I don't have to say that this is
probably just dangerous overall does
this mean I'm gonna have eight husband's
just hanging underneath all these
ladders made it and here we are
reflection what are the goggles for
what's gonna protect the rest of me
what's gonna protect my spirit and my
soul going out with my boots on and my
shirt off like a true redneck how we're
doing this all right I don't want to do
this if my life is gonna suck from here
on out this is my aggression do the
thing that's gonna [ __ ] up my life Oh
Lord be with me today Oh
that was so cool but I'm so scared why
do I still have these goggles on oh
that's you shabby I guess I just look
this is gonna like fly on me though like
today the Angels and whoever's up
there's gonna have to be working extra
hard we'll see if I'm still alive later
on feel like I had like an exceptionally
good week a week went by pretty smoothly
I'm definitely glad about the
experiences I feel like it helped me
take power away from those things in a
sense when you think something positive
is gonna happen you kind of make it
happen for yourself at the end of the
day it's just the way that you view
things like if somebody were to tell you
that if you actually break a mirror
that's good luck then you're gonna
believe that it's gonna be good luck and
it's gonna just change the way that you
live your life on a daily I think
I really think this broke a lot of
barriers for me like I did everything I
could to make my luck awful and this
week was actually pretty good now if it
was Mercury retrograde then that'd be a
different story then I'd be like oh I
would never break another mirror again
cuz maybe bad luck was like oh [ __ ]
they're filming us I won't be showing up
this round